[Music]
you see taxis are ubers the stars are
youtubers neil dyson gave pluto the axe
cell phones got smarter the oceans got
hotter the global economy collapsed
we get internet deals on our hype and it
meals like h3 vegan paleo sausage
we don't leave our homes thanks to
amazon drones they track what we do
through our washrooms
what's going on will we be okay since we
went away oh update us please run out of
jokes
2016 should be a real breed so hillary
finally broke that glass ceiling
no but it certainly does feel like it's
raining shards of glass all around us
the concrete's got into the red and the
blue face looks a toxic install
the box springs are done and that is the
president
at least we think they're still a
president trump you see the writers are
writing this in 2018.
how is that possible the people rely on
anime likes for outrageous and relevant
content
how can we finish catching up but we
don't know what happened in the last two
years
i don't know wild guesses sounds good to
me we have chips in our brains we no
longer feel pain there are worsening
climate disasters now we live
underground and we can't make a sound
left out for revenge without arms on our
factory farms
[Music]
it's about a talking police car who's
also a time machine
wow here comes the star club i travel
through time
our ratings depend on knowing the trends
that's how this song is